we have a clip here from a classic Bruce
Lee film Game of Death to familiarize
ourselves with the master let's take a
look okay I got it yeah all I had to do
was see that and I think I memorized it
all I am ready to go do you think I can
pull this off yeah let's experience the
essence of Bruce okay first I'm going to
warm up and really get into the Bruce
Lee mode right here
as you said you saw and as you saw in
the clip yes yeah this was very fluid
fluid and he believed in life and in
fighting to be like water 2/4 you must
be like water many people have told me I
am a lot like water well you're not as a
coordinated or graceful probably as
Bruce was but you you have long with it
I'm sorry what a Dickey thing to say
right here up top when I look like this
you will pay for your words what's the
first thing I have to know we'll get
warmed up we're about yeah what do I
have to learn or another fighting sense
let's just open up our hips open up our
hips like that ok I'm pretty good at
that if you know what I mean oh now that
is now that you kind of have that let's
extend I look like a banana having a
seizure how was this do okay what do I
do
let's extender this called a crescent
kick so nope anything but you extend
your leg and you go out and round the
circle it looks like a dance kick but if
you put them some torque on wow that was
incredible becomes very dead did you I
felt and I felt myself go back in time I
met Lincoln for a second okay you want
to try it yeah what do I have to do to
go that tell me one more time here do it
you go from here
I'll be around up and around you you
bring the knee up and then around that
right okay
[Applause]
Wow yeah you gotta make sure 84 you
gotta keep hitting me for got to keep
your guard up anything about keeping my
guard up we did that the last show we
talked about that okay okay so let's see
the things that guy so but keep your
guard up okay my guards up in an hour
[Applause]
[Applause]
I am like water okay so keep that in
mind okay and now let's work on footwork
okay footwork okay so so Bruce in the
60s was one of the few martial artists
that actually was inspired by western
boxing okay so in the 60s most martial
artists have really traditional stances
yeah and Bruce believed in doing that
but also staying light like a cat like a
cat though he was very much like a cat
like a cat or like a bull in a very
strong stance so you I would move
between being a cat right and being oh
so that's our drill we're gonna do so
why are they here seriously I thought
they were from the audience for a second
I've noticed in the past when we've done
drills like this you would often hide
behind your desk yeah
so these gentlemen will set it's also a
great Bruce Lee technique when he's been
doing office work yeah so wait they're
here if I try to run away they're gonna
do what they're gonna hit you okay yeah
all right so you stay here with me okay
we didn't discuss any of this in
rehearsal all right and then what do you
want hand I'll use my haul counts wait a
minute when I then this is not a
standard fighting scenario Bruce Lee
I've seen all the movies he never
encountered a guy with large green Hulk
hands okay so when I say cat right do
you Bruce Lee cats stay like they let it
kind of kind of there you go
more coordination more coordination more
coordination with motivation now bull
bull give in to Bullock Stan's bull
fighting stance guys come and tighter
tighter tighter let's bring it in okay
okay here we go yes
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
[Applause]
catgut catch up wait a minute hey wait a
minute
hey what kind of crappy exercise was
that I learned nothing there you should
have learned to be more like water you
got to go with the flow
yeah with what's around you they're
going to renew their gym membership
you